well I'm curious cuz I watched your Vlog
you did with duno where you guys were in
in your area which which was dope duno
man great guy love duno most Mexican
person I ever met for real that's on he
should put that on a on a t-shirt merch
La um but I'm curious cuz like when you
were locked up he's humble man he's a
humble do know for sure what like do you
remember hearing about nipy passing away
and how he passed away when you were
incarcerated yeah I do I remember that
day nipy was my favorite rapper I wish I
could be more like I'm nothing like nipy
his mind was just sick like I said I
want to be the Mexican y but like nipy
was just his mentality and the thing
that he did the way he made all money in
grinding all my life all that just is
legendary best rapper top three one of
mine top three rappers all time
nipy
Eminem probably the G game probably not
yeah dog man Spas homies on the gang huh
those FS are hard you know they are
hopefully I'm your favorite rapper top I
had name top three all time Eminem nipy
Hustle the
game those are good three Tupac hard too
but n those guys number four I'm going
with the game
nipsy so if you the third one NY Gunplay
if you and wack end up doing this fade
you just challenged him to on a on
community he's not going to do it man if
you win you get a game verse you know
what man you know what I'm going say
like this I don't think he knows like he
did let me tell you like this I got it I
don't think he meant it like that n
whack's a good dude bro that's cool and
I give it I give every person the
benefit of the doubt but like like yeah
I clown around F but like I'm not
playing out here like I don't give a
[__] for like I'm really from where I'm
from I don't care about this [__] like
you I'm from a gang and I got my homies
behind me and I don't care if somebody's
dissing me I'm going diss him I don't
think he meant it that way that's why
I'm not taking it the whole and I'm
pretty sure he would take it the whole
way against me too I know he does I know
he does no I know he does my bad I know
he does talk down on Mexicans I don't
talk down on blacks I do not I've been
in jail that's cool I I don't even know
who the [__] he is dog like I really
don't I just did N9 years in Pelican Bay
and I I heard who he had signed he had
some artist and stuff I wouldn't sign
with him you know what I'm saying just I
be a sellout he if you guys met you guys
would get along if he met I'll come at
him Embrace him but I know he's probably
going to you know be like [__] [__] him
dog you know without giving me the
benefit of the doubt so you know shout
outs to him but he said like I never
shot [__] like he don't know me dog
right you know that's a good answer cuz
I yeah and real reality yeah I never
shot [__] you know don't but you don't
know my life you don't know what I've
been through I don't know your life I
don't know who you are you know what I'm
saying everybody has a ly you know what
I'm saying like dog like I said for you
ask for like trouble I'm not threatening
him or nothing but like I don't give a
[__] right you know what I'm saying like
I'm I don't give a [__] he's a
businessman I don't give a he ain't a
businessman for saying that though no
but he a bu we I ain't a businessman I'm
trying to do something I'm the best La
rapper this a essay you better check the
[__] resume dog before you talk
about me dog on a gang I'm really
tripping like that dead homies I don't
give a [__] about this [__] talk about
him like that no I don't talk about him
like that or his people like that that
[__] ain't cool dog I'll never do [__]
with him I wouldn't he's cool shout outs
to him I'll never do nothing with him
dead homies bang that it's like that I'm
tripping like I'm tripping dog like that
[__] ain't cool [__] him I said it [__]
him it is what it is dog we W to do a
show there wherever he's at [__] him my
bad [__] him dog I'm sorry guys [__] him
I'll be letting down my my people dog
[__] him dog I'll be letting I'll be a
sellout I'll be a sellout embracing it
nah I'm cool cool on him [__] him I
heard what he said well let's change the
subject n [__] that I'm already want to
uh finish it up we're good I I'm sorry F
they so you were saying on Sunday that's
how I feel though I keep it real I can't
go to sleep with anything bottled inside
if you got to feel something on your
chest get it off your chest I ain't fake
I'm real [__] you next question my bad
sorry my bad you going to have to he
let's lighten it up hey what's your
favorite football team the Raiders the
Raiders I'm sorry they suck huh they
barely made it well you think the
problem was I can't even get back to it
after that one I'm tripping I feel hot
fool I'm too ghetto to be on this [__]
huh I heard what you said my boy I be a
sellout fool shout out to the S Mexican
Community that's a big old subject I
don't do that I love black people I love
blacks I love s why he trying to uh put
a put put a line between it when we
trying to break that right you trying to
put a line between it like make us beef
it like I [__] with blue face you know
what I'm saying I [__] with the game I'm
doing a game remak why you do that dog
like I [__] love Bloods I love some
cribs dog they're the homies I'm sure
yall clear it up no n hell no he doing
it too much dog well let's get to the
Raiders but I'm the first real I'm the
first real I'm the first real Latino
fresh up out of jail 30 days ago dog and
I'm telling you that's not cool dog it's
not right and people are just saying
that it's cool it's not right somebody
with a platform has to say [__] that
it's not cool dog if he wants to stop
doing that and be like you know what I
didn't mean it like that that's cool we
could do it but I doubt they I would I
wouldn't exchange my hands to it's not
cool he knows what's right and what's
wrong and that's not right it ain't
right and I'm not cool with it saying I
would do it I had to get it off my chest
it's a big subject you going to go viral
[__] viral it's just real [__] that's
it's not right I got a platform I'm
going speak I don't like that [__] dog
if he wants to do it to each is his own
do it but I ain't [__] with him dead
homies he he putting a line between the
boundary when we're breaking that like
it's about it's about Unity that's what
I was saying earlier about Unity I love
black I just came from a black podcast
you know it's about Unity man I think uh
I think he'll clear that up man she
could wack I know one thing wack ain't
racist I think he is dog I think he is
man they keep asking me I think he I
think he is do you think the Raiders
should keep Antonio Pierce actually I'm
going to keep a g I don't think he is
last thing fool I don't think he is I
think he's just talking [__] cuz I would
say some [__] if I didn't give a [__]
about the camera but they train me so
good I think he's just talking [__] like
he don't mean it like that maybe he
don't mean it like that but it comes out
with that like that cuz sometimes I be
talking [__] but I got to watch what I
say on camera right now I'm talking [__]
and I don't think he means it like that
I don't think he me it like that I think
he's just like so like that's whack 100
whatever you know he has his artist he's
Cash Money West and he's just like [__]
it [__] everybody I'm just talking [__]
real La [__] you got a long career ahead
of you bro I do that's what everybody
says I got a never mind I was going to
say joke no you no you really do have a
long career ahead of you bro like yeah I
hope so man I really do I really do just
you nobody wants to see anybody like you
know the whole thing you know I don't
want to see you crash out you know what
I'm saying or or get yourself into a
situation where no I'm going to be hot
forever that's my biggest dream that's
my biggest down fa I get what you're
saying is to have not be hot and ruin my
career over one thing and it could
happen it could happen at any time don't
take it for granted yeah um and if it
happens it happens F [__] it [__] it hey
[__] it I'm still going to keep rapping
nah bro you got a long career ahead of
you you're just getting started and the
other thing is like you like you could
really like bar out you know what I'm
saying like you really could rap rap for
real for real like yeah you know what
I'm say I'm very impressed by your your
your skill level you know what I'm going
to say like this dog like hey dog I get
high dog like I do drink every day like
I'm [__] in the hood every day I
don't give a [__] fool I'm in the hood
every day like Fool's don't understand
like what the [__] I'm going through and
if you do cool if you talk [__] cool I
still got more money than you cool I'm
still better than you I still got two
banjos you can't be happy for me I'm
happy for anybody doing it I don't even
know what the [__] I'm saying right now
I'm just saying like so what I'm drunk
I'm high I don't give a [__] I look at
all the comments and they always say the
same [__] like like what man oh he's
high whatever like man you sound like a
cop every comment like parole officer
like I'm high so what my mom knows I'm
high everybody knows I'm high they told
me to stop I ain't going to stop I'll
stop you know when when I when I stop
what is your uh your drug of choice all
kinds of [__] just everything all kinds
of [__] all kinds of things like I don't
give a [__] like I'm trying catching up
to everybody I'm young for the for
camera purposes marijuana right hell no
that's sh that right now I'm on
marijuana that's why I'm talking this
[__] weed is great I don't even I think
we should edit this weed [__] just
gets me like weed gets me like this fool
just dumb hey we gets me thinking fool
I'm thinking on this [__] now I got to
get off this [__] I told you get me off
it let me go bounce and go do a mother
[__] fre go do let's yeah yeah Frey
go do a little walk all right yo hey but
I give him the best interview I think I
give you a really good interview I agree
brother you're going to edit it right
here and we'll wrap it up at the end I
appreciate you I think he's like looking
at me like [__] Lefty shut the [__] up
like
on just embracing you I'm trying to help
you out dog he ain't going to put in
what you don't want exctly here our
friend man you're good okay but tell Cam
too hey Lefty he don't mean no harm
that's how he is can't right you're good
actually like this for sure he no you're
good brother hey man I think you're dope
I